[موسيقى]
تسلحت بالذكاء الاصطناعي فوضعت نفسها في
مقدمه شركات الرقائق الالكترونيه
الامريكيه حتى وصلت قيمتها السوقيه الى
تريليون دولار بعد تهافت المستثمرين على
شراء اسهمها انها شركه انفيديا كورب عملاق
الرقائق الالكترونيه
[موسيقى]
ثمانيه اشهر تضاعفت قيمه سهم شركه انفيديا
ثلاث مرات فمنذ اكتوبر عام 2022 ارتفعت
اسهمها بنحو 200% وقبل ايام قليله من شهر
مايو عام 2023 قفز السهم بنسبه اربعه في
المئه في تداول ما قبل السوق الى
404.9 دولار ومنح الشركه تقييما ارشاديا
للسوق بلغ تريليون دولار رقم ضخم جدا
يقارن باقتصادات دول الكبرى فعائدات دوله
كفرنسا مثلا لم تتجاوز ذلك الرقم وهذا ان
دل على شيء فانه يدل على ان الذكاء
الاصطناعي سيساهم في تغيير ملامح عالم
الشركات والاعمال
[موسيقى]
الذكاء الاصطناعي خلق منافسه جديده بين
شركات التكنولوجيا بالعالم محللون اشاروا
الى ان شركه انفيديا تعتبر اهم شركه على
هذا الكوكب في عصر الذكاء الاصطناعي وهي
تمضي قدما نحو تحقيق اعلى سعر مستهدف لسهم
الشركه لتلحق بشركات اخرى تفوق قيمتها
تريليونات الدلعات
التاسعه على مستوى العالم التي تحقق هذا
الانجاز وهناك خمس شركات اخرى فقط في جميع
انحاء العالم تتمتع بهذا التميز وهي شركه
ارامكو السعوديه وابل وميكروسوفت وجوجل
وامازونا
واحده من اكبر الشركات انتاجا لمعالجات
الرسومات وبطاقات العرض المرئي في العالم
هنا يستعرض الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه
منتجاتها في معرض كمبيوتكس في تايوان قبل
ايام فكلمه السر نحو التريليون دولار
تمثلت في حصول الشركه على طلبيات كبيره
قامت بتوفيرها بالفعل وواكبت التكنولوجيا
اللازمه لموجه الابتكارات والتقنيات ذات
الاستخدامات المتعدده حدثت طفره في نمو
هذه الشركه وتصدرت السباق الان لكن
المخاوف بحسب الخبراء هي حدوثه هبوط مفاجئ
مثل الذي حدث مع تسلا بعد ان كان الثانيه
اسرع شركه بالتاريخ تتخطى حاجز التريليون
دولار لكنها خسرت لاحقا 50% من قيمتها
السوقيه التي بلغت سابقا 1.2 ترليون دولار
لتصل اليوم الى 633
مليار دولار فقط
[موسيقى]